enfin vous tous les trente ans qui nous
qui nous font subir sa route sur votre
bureau
un trophée de sangliers en cadeau les
agriculteurs de haute saône ont voulu
rappeler au ministre de l'écologie
également de la chasse leur exaspération
face à un dossier qui pour eux revient
trop souvent les dégâts dans les
cultures que provoquent ces animaux des
sangliers toujours en surnombre pour les
agriculteurs et des agriculteurs
inquiets d'un possible changement
d'interlocuteur
concernant justement le dossier et
sangles l'état abandonnent une partie de
ses prérogatives dans les départements
pour donner un peu plus de liberté et de
de pouvoir de décision aux présidents
départementaux des fédérations de chasse
ça nous ne voulons pas nous voulons
conserver comme interlocuteur privilégié
sur le domaine de la chasse le préfet
dans les départements françois de rugy
est à l' écoute les changes se fait sous
son hangar dans cette ferme north oil
bourg pas très loin de vesoul entouré
d'agriculteurs d'élus une visite
d'exploitation pour le ministre qui face
au dossier des sangliers une véritable
problématique dans le département a tenu
donc moi j'ai un discours de fermeté
vis-à-vis des fédérations de chasseurs
en disant vous devez jouer votre rôle de
régulation à des populations de
sangliers comme ça peut être le cas
aussi sur les serres et pour trouver des
solutions concrètes aux agriculteurs qui
ne peuvent pas continuer à subir des
dégâts de gibier aussi important qui ne
peuvent pas simplement recevoir des
indemnisations
il y aura eu le dossier des sangliers
mais pas que d'autres thématiques tout
au long de la journée
la valorisation des déchets le matin les
énergies renouvelables l'agriculture le
bois l'automobile après midi et un grand
débat national en soirée à la mairie de
luxueil débat